[Music]
hey guys it's boise new and today i have
some sweet bass tingling news for
everyone out there creative came
knocking at our door and today i have
the long witted successor to the katana
the katana v2
so before we get into the review i just
want to let the folks at creative know
that i'm a huge fan of yours i've been
using the z sound d3x since 2012 up to
this day so for your prospective
creative buyers out there once you get a
creative get a creative for life we
reviewed the original katana back in
2017 and we're still pumping tracks on
this baby it still sounds perfect clear
and loud as the day we unboxed it my z
sound d3x has been alive for nine years
this thing has been around for four
years and if that doesn't tell you
anything about the build quality that
creative is putting out i really have
nothing else to say they really make
products that last you for life these
things are as good as air looms search
up any review on the original katana and
they only have good things to say and i
believe that all your current users out
there would agree that this thing is a
brilliant piece of hardware however
the v2 over here cranks it up to 11.
which is a spinal tap job
guys don't catch that across the board
so back in 2016 you know the market for
gaming sound bars wasn't exactly as
prominent as it is today creative came
in at the right time and delivered this
thing complete with phenomenal
near-field audio and also rgb
rgb
oh damn it is it rgb now yeah and also
rgb which is essential for you gamers
out there because it makes you play
better
so quite honestly you know this gaming
sound bar here was all you ever needed
back then i was planning to pick one up
for myself until i found out that
creative had other plans for me and
released the v2
and i only have two things to say about
this
scout mode
so before we get into scout mode i need
to talk about sxfi mode or as we like to
call it sexify mode so battle mode
enhances the audio in game it basically
highlights a lot of the enemy footsteps
their reloads their movements and
everything so you have a better idea of
where the enemies are especially in
games like pubg or rainbow six so the
thing about battle mode is that it's
only available while you're using
headphones however you can use scalp
mode with or without headphones which is
pretty insane because now
i don't think i need headphones anymore
so the thing about battle mode and scout
board you can think of them as sort of
like equalizers battle mode on its own
was pretty damn good
however scalable triples on that and
makes it even clearer
so quite honestly for both modes whether
you're a hardcore gamer or just a casual
you will have an edge over everyone else
in that lobby it almost feels like it's
cheating with scalp mode i don't even
need headphones to do that and speaking
of headphones there is a headphone jack
on the katana v2 which you can plug it
in and enjoy scout mode as well and
there's literally no way i can explain
how amazing the experience is
just so you can get a better idea of how
scout mode sounds like on we're gonna
run some footage of it on and off with
the speakers without headphones on
obviously
but you know it's not the best way of
testing out audio because you need to be
here you know in person with the product
but you know
it is what it is
but you know just just take our word for
it because like it's really good like
i
it's it's really good
so this is footage of the katana v2
without scout mode
and this is footage of the katana v2
with scout mode on
so scout mode pad with adobe 5.1
surround sound enhances the sound
staging which in other words means that
your audio experience becomes way better
especially if you're a gamer because it
does a lot for you in terms of
information gathering especially in
games like pubg rainbow six warzone
anything to do with tactical shooters
and battle royals this is what you need
so comparing the original katana to the
v2 the first thing you notice obviously
is that the v2 retains a lot of the
original attributes of the first katana
so apart from the brush metal finish the
v2 also retains the button layout on the
top the v2 now has an led panel in the
front and the headphone jack has been
relocated from the back of the katana to
the front for easy access another thing
about the katana v2 is that there is
reactive lighting so let's test it out
and see how it reacts with music
it even reacts to in-game sounds
so this is a massive upgrade from the
original katanas rgb controls
and the other thing that you can't tell
is that there are two microphones at the
front
so these microphones pick up audio
pretty well and creative had this design
in mind for people who sit through hours
and hours of conference calls especially
for people who wear glasses everything
is going to hurt so creative has a
solution for that with the microphones
at the front and playback at the same
time without feedback
or
interference
this is how it sounds like with the
katana v2s built-in microphones
this is how it sounds like with
headphones plugged into the katana v2
so talking about connectivity both
katanas have bluetooth optical out usbs
and auxiliary ports for your aux cords
the v2 also comes with a hdmi port which
is compatible with all your consoles and
a 65 out usb port compatible with all 65
headphone dongles
so the other difference between the
original katana and the v2 are the sizes
of the subwoofer so this thing goes at
about 5.25 inches while this is at 6.5
inches which just means there's more
bass
so speaking of other things that come
with the v2 are wall mounts we also have
extra power cables for you guys outside
of singapore for all of our
international friends out there and
lastly we also have our new remote which
comes with programmable buttons and also
an option for you to increase the
brightness of your rgb which the
original
remote could not do so say you guys lose
your remote i don't know how but if you
lose it you technically have a second
remote with the creative app on your
phone so with the creative app you guys
can change up your volumes your rgb
profiles basically anything to do with
the katana
you can do it with the phone
so final thoughts on the v2 you know
creative has outdone themselves again
i'm pretty sure you guys who own the
original katana would know what i'm
talking about and would know what to
expect from the v2 i know it's a lot of
praise that i'm giving for the v2 but
honestly until you get your hands on one
of these
only then would you understand where i'm
coming from so whether you're a gamer an
audiophile or just someone who wants a
new speaker for their home
this thing does the job it is versatile
as heck you can put in front of your
computer you can use it as a home
theater system you can blast it at
parties it's everything you need in your
samba the v2 costs 329 us dollars which
is just 30 off from the v1
you might as well get the v2 once it
releases price point on this thing it's
solid performance it's fantastic rgbness
the gods are appeased i've checked with
them they're cool with it so if you guys
enjoyed this video please leave a like
and subscribe to us if you have not
already that helps us out a lot let us
know in the comments if you guys are
going to pick one up for yourselves
because i know i will
right so
that's all this is your boy zinio
signing off and i'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
you